[Musik]
wie so häufig wie gute geschichte fort
die mit releganten im jurassischen dorf
lassen erhält im 17 jahrhundert
großhandel sind kaputt die heimische
ganz flickr ein junger schmid daniel
shore sicht reparatur clown einfacher
helga beschlossen
sauberer zu bauen und so hat es
angefangen mit der schweizer
uhrenindustrie
denn
unterwegs im jura in der hauptklage
natale und hoch aber nina romano frauen
sieht 400 jahresverdienste handflächen
von daher hoch kompliziert die türe und
äußerst erfolgreiche nur dass nach den
schweizerinnen und die beste oder
vorgänger verloren gehabt
das erste ziel ist im waadtländer jura
[Musik]
würzburger fv der erotischste und
weltweit renommierteste oder manufaktur
von große uhren in die ställe nicolas
hayek man dort vom großvater mit zwei
musik und athletik manufaktur für luxus
und swatch konzern
vorschau zur kritik macht rund 50
verschiedene prüfsiegel hier geprägte
versetzte marc hayek die meisten von den
angestellten sich fachlich vater fläche
jahrhunderte auf und dabei die zum teil
mit einer maschine oder druck bestimmt
und graviert werden wenn man das machen
geht machen
darum das ist ganz ganz wichtige punkte
alle blätter sind engagiert und das
kürzere dms bietet alles andere als
normal besucher marke braucht die
industrie trug nicht nur mit was macht
also ständig oder für das stück ist aus
kunst aus einer richtung
es ist ein beruf und 60 produktionen und
der wurf muss am leben halten werden
die brücke hat mit seiner findiger
maßstab für präzisions uhrmacherei bis
100 neue bulgarische im 18 jahrhundert
ausgewandert und hec paris ein große
karriere gemacht
königin marie antoinette napoleon
bonaparte und russische zar seine
kostbare oder begann später die
grossisten george in otterstadt pianist
arthur rubinstein dazu kommen
es ist an der b2 brügge und exklusiv
macht der cloud mit dem markt
[Musik]
frank rost als extrem vermied es lebe
die grundschule es ist ganz klar im
vorteil
eine mechanische uhr und im prinzip so
lange es aber fair zum die reparieren
ins gedächtnis
ja natürlich sind kopieren aber dass
weder darauf noch einmal einen punkt
nützlich wenn es mehr oder weniger so
ausgemacht
ok wenn die geister kopieren das
fotografieren aus aller welt aber kein
platz das genau wie genau das ist ein
kulturvolk und das buch von migrationen
und dann berufen und sage das ist der
moment wo ist ihre innovations- machen
technologie vorwärts treiben denn zimmer
20 ist nicolas hayek brücke 1905 kauft
es wurde sofort die jagd ist die
hochkomplizierte uhr nachts bohren oder
brücken sind für königin marie
antoinette
[Musik]
mit in unschlagbarer segen für die große
schritt hätte die uhr im innen- und
russlands gegen bietet präsentiert hat
eine riesige werk ein einzelstück
aus dem atelier und übertrumpfen
zu ehren von nikolaus hammerschmidt
großvater und was ist jetzt speziell
darum die hand über 200 einzelteile 1
tobias angerer minutenrepetition einem
tag und nacht damit der lang
funktioniert oft der grund sondern wo
sich verändert aktion am morgen oder am
abend stehen wahrscheinlich zwei
millionen euro
in diesem preis ist implizit nicht aber
es ist das herz der mieter aber nicht
zur folge
geburtstages ist ganz ganz spezielles
das ist schön und dafür mit marc hayek
zu rappen der legenden im betrieb zum
uhrmacher und dann hätt brücke überlebt
also das ist ganz ganz alt
in acht mädels so ruhige und ganzen im
heim ist gerade der blick
hier ist geboren hier hätte aber lang
rom sowie sie vater und großvater stammt
vom französischen hugenotten sagt sato
sie bezahlt jahrhundert jurack flüchtet
sie das ist etwa für salon meines
großvaters die meinen vater übernahm
mitte der 1950 er jahre schloss er das
geschäft und begann im oberen stockwerk
als uhrmacher zu arbeiten
als ich noch ganz klein war setzte ich
mich jeweils schon frühmorgens auf
seinen schoß um ihm bei der arbeit
zuzuschauen
damit ich überhaupt etwas musste er das
knie etwas anheben was er mit den uhren
machte verstand ich damals natürlich
noch nicht unter der decke uhrmacher
familie für seine vorfahren verwandten
schumacher geschafft
in sauberes handwerk chance lena burk
fasziniert wie weihnachten wünschte ich
mir einmal einen alten wecker
auseinanderzunehmen zu verstehen wozu
die rede da sagte meine mutter wo soll
ich hin finden diesen alten wecker und
dann april war von tanja und dann suchte
ich im abfall nach solchen dingen die
motörhead sail city der uhrenfabrik
scharf wie die meisten bewohner vom
ballett schuh kann man sagen dass die
leute jeder eine besondere begabung für
dieses handwerk haben
ich glaube sie wurden dazu gezwungen
es gab ja nichts im winter konnten die
leute irgendwo hin wegen des schnees
viele von ihnen waren bauern und
beschäftigten sich in den langen
wintermonaten zu hause mit der
uhrmacherei sie hatten auf dem hof
kleine atelier ist mit vielen fenstern
damit sie genügend licht hatten für die
knifflige arbeit so fertigten sie im
auftrag von firmen uhren bestandteile an
sittliche sie wiegt verstreut die
details von julian münch award arona
bretleben geständig und sie herr harry
arbeitsraum handwerk fotogen autos
frankreich gebracht hätte im jura und
später jura sie die ideale heimat
gezwungen wie der aufstand jetzt richtig
los von der staatsoper im neuenburger
jura
[Musik]
die schule machen
als internationaler museums la chaux de
fonds
[Musik]
statt ist fragt vor der uhrenindustrie
des stromverbrauchs
unesco-weltkulturerbe stuttgart muss im
ort beklagt mit ludwig irrsinn
zusammenhang
was mich ärgert ist dass laut wollen
standen ich an respekt für den industrie
new york san francisco und so dass ich
alles instand und genau mit dem
schachbrettmuster hingegen bastos die
spezielle gemüse gesehen sind aber dass
es für spezifische gerichtet wurden ist
also mitarbeiter straßenmitte vorgängige
garten und alters ist er speziell im 19
jahrhundert sich die schweiz als
billiglohnland sie madame de tourvel
hier weltweit konkurrenzfähig
bürgermeister ludwig joslin vor
architektur typisch für la
chaux-de-fonds mitarbeiter schließlich
mit der langen strecke wieder
obergeschoss in denen sich lina
uhrmacher atelier wo lehrlinge auch
hinschaute
[Musik]
vergebens linke uffenheim sieht froh für
die arbeit besonders kräftig sie und die
großzügige garten studien oder im
handwerk also die garten sind erklärt
wurde weil der umgang und darum geht's
um good luck fall aber mit genügend
möglichkeiten zum duschen sie und legt
dabei selber bilder vom süden her
natürlich meisterlicher für die abteile
trifft dort die fensterfront bürger
sinken ausgerichtet die pompöse
fabrikantenvilla siebziger von bonitaire
uhrmacher an die nun seit jahrhunderten
die erste fabriken entstanden
schweizer uhren zum auto baut markt
dominiert typisch für laschet vor dem
gebäudekomplex die extrem starke
durchwachsen und durchweg vor
lebensbereich und arbeitsbereiche
siebter direkt fabrik und auf der
anderen seite angeschlossen sofort
fabrik wurde chef vor der fabrik drinnen
gewohnten la chaux de fonds bisher nur
am rand vorstand hässliche letzten jahr
ging mir bekannte marken excellence
dieses ist aber die französische moderne
manufaktur gemacht deshalb mit diesem
bauernhof
wir wollen uns dort zurück besinnen auf
die uhrmacher tradition in dieser
regierung und auch den sammler und
unsere uhren ausserhalb der schweiz
diese wurzeln erbringen das ist es auch
eine art marketing
nicht unbedingt
es ist wirklich ein hinweis darauf dass
die uhren hier früher so produziert
worden modernen gebäude aus dem 21
jahrhundert dass wir uns die zukunft
symbolisiert sie haben diese beiden
elemente die sich perfekt ergänzen sowie
bei unseren ohren auch da verbinden wir
die alte tradition mit einer völlig
neuen technologie
das harmoniert ihre moderne klaus bohl
beschäftige grübel und 74 glück dass die
region für uhrmacher steven forsi
handwerk ursprünglich sein glanz klärt
die schweizer perfektionieren und da
hätte der elsässer robert grübel
erkennen
2004 helsinki mal gegründet
die jungen firma göbel und vorsätzlich
in kurzer zeit im luxus-segment tür
gesetzt kostet ca 350 und 850 franken
ohne edelsteine
können sie uns erklären was ihre uhren
so teuer macht ich glaube nicht dass sie
teuer sind
ich finde sie sind teuer jedenfalls ich
konnte mir keiner leisten
das will ja nicht heißen dass sie teuer
sind
schauen sie eine grippe uhr ist eine art
unikat
[Musik]
wir produzieren nur rund 100 stück pro
jahr
das heißt es steckt sehr viel arbeit
konzentration und ruhe bis vom
wichtigste beim handwerk
er braucht eine solche uhr braucht das
wir hatten diesen willen diese
leidenschaft frisuren handwerk das seit
jahrhunderten besteht
es ist die aufgabe des uhrmachers dafür
zu sorgen dass dieses handwerk nicht
verloren geht und es voranzutreiben
das braucht natürlich braucht es auch
jene die bereit sind diese zu
unterstützen und eine solche aber kaufen
es ist ein zusammenspiel mit ihm
internationale museumsrat von den vier
haupttäter
herzstück
erotische fantasien emi
so sehen wir für den pausenhof tina
[Musik]
schütze uhrenindustrie hat schnell auf
montag und reagiere und sonderwünsche
befriedigen
was passiert jetzt also bei der nur dass
ich das planetarium und kommen in
sie trafen planeten um zu unternehmer
logo also zonen im zentrum und merkur
venus erde mit mond mars jupiter und
saturn plus der uranus ganz ende auf
planeten planeten stimmung zu
unternehmen
er war selber ze die astronomische uhr
also die nächste taktische brückl und
bearbeitet um überhaupt im größere
folgen zeigen wie es funktioniert dass
sie sich also vorstellen könne man rein
vom philosophischen standpunkt habe als
sie die werte der größe und nicht mehr
im gesamtraum
im low fazit zur quarter vor der kreatur
bruder über dich zusammen
und nach der taschenuhr ist im 20
jahrhundert anbandelt
es ist jetzt eine taschenuhr gebracht
wurden ist damit man sie am abend
gegenüber der kleider und der trend
entwickelt im verlauf vom ersten
weltkrieg und dazu hat insbesondere im
militärbereich immer eine spätere
stadium zum taschenuhr lanschützer oder
zum tour wo man am abend ein schütze hat
man den energieträger insbesondere bei
offizier was einige uhren tragen
das sind trends es wird also noch ein
paar das für die who von anderen tour
aber durch entweder tragen und nach
bayerische den wirklich aus hand lang
unter der nachfrage nach armbanduhren
nimmt gerne zur spiels kranker und
solothurn stadtzentrum 1929 er schied
schon 50 liegt in der uhrenindustrie
schaffen
nach der krise der briesker jahr hätte
industrie im 2
derart zucker produziert und liefert dir
und liebt sie es gerade der so genannte
uhr statt hetze vor der konkurrenz
geschützt
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg sie ging mehr
menschen aus dem ausland fabrik rom
italienische frau die sie meistens und
qualifiziert sie bei genf linke hand
aber fragt erwartet von der arbeit aus
dem neuenburgischen florian die jahr gut
noch mittel ab valeria general solches
18-jährige fortaleza und mit die 60er
jahre uhrenindustrie wir ausländerinnen
hatten einen schlechteren ansatz als die
schweizerinnen
das heißt wir verdienten weniger da wir
aber pro stück bezahlt worden und
schnell arbeiteten verdienten wir
manchmal mehr als die schweizerinnen
sobald sie diese bemerkten reklamierten
sie beim chef
nach dem 2 weltkrieg dass ich für die
frau hätte und frau monotonie arbeit xin
traurige berühmtheit dem zusammenhang
die so genannte santoro arbeitete jeder
brot mit tabletten tropfen belebt besser
die arbeits umstand hätte sich mühsam
erkämpfen
da wo ich gearbeitet habe wollten sie
nichts von der gewerkschaft wissen
das war indiskutabel ich war das
schwarze schaf weil ich hinter
gewerkschaft war auch wenn die
gesellschaft der uhrenindustrie nicht
besonders kämpferisch war genau
trotzdem sie wollten nichts davon hören
es war nicht lustig so informierte ich
meine arbeitskolleginnen während der
pausen oder auf der toilette
es gab immer irgendeine gelegenheit
[Musik]
ibm heutige zentrum vor der
uhrenindustrie und honda gut mit dem ceo
von der swatch gruppe gebaut wird
führender schweizer uhrenhersteller 25
angestellte schaffen vertrag von seien
weit mehr wert auf die davor die schweiz
bevor ihr vater das bissen sich stecken
ist dass ich das gefühl dass ich so
alles notwendig das ist stabil 14
[Musik]
peter mondlandung 1969 astronauten
schweizer uhren und rohwaren apollo
twitter flog sie stehen bagger und vsv
sie hätten omega öko vor dem navigieren
gesunde dankbarkeit von der nasa groß
ziehen
[Musik]
die ganze welt heute läuft und die hand
natürlich ein omega speedmaster ammann
schweiz ruhe und ich habe mehr anonym
betrugen ca ich habe mir das gewünscht
und die hat das geschenk der familie ja
so eine uhr geschenkt und ich hatte
immer drei immer besser moment wozu
lanciert wurden ist den handelsort
strecke vorher habe ich aber zu deiner
kategorie gehört wo immer die lehre und
reitern wie man sie ja könnte sich noch
unter nun rechts weiter damit sie schön
und der paul hartmann island vielleicht
mal ein anderer überhaupt ist und der
paul thoma die und ja genau das durch
macht der gewohnheit wechsel also bin
ich die omega der mondlandung in die
schweiz der kroate präsentiert aber für
schweizer uhren barone ist kurz nur
spielerei xii sie hat begriffen dass die
elektronik tour verändert so platt
gemacht wenn die mechanische der
amerikaner später japaner hat sehr wohl
begriffen
sie hätte markt mit gängigen
elektronische urawa beliefere
schweizer uhrenfabrikant präsident auf
dem höhepunkt folgt oft kurz revolution
sie herüber astronauten general und
könige durch ihre fabrik geführt so wie
jetzt teilen die königspaare
[Musik]
extravagant und tiere die stück
fortführt
[Musik]
aber sie hält es auch in atlanta die
industrie ist campbell endet amerikaner
und japaner zurück
[Applaus]
mit die fotoserie ist es definitiv
erstklassig frauen und männer ohne job
verloren
schweizer industrie ist vernünftig
aufgestellt die schrumpft
es war traurig ich arbeitete damals
bereits 19 jahre in der uhrenindustrie
es war mein zweites zuhause die angst
begleitet er uns ständig wir hatten
keine ahnung wohin wir gehen sollten
wem arbeiten wir mussten wieder ganz von
vorne beginnen
für sie war das überhaupt nicht einfach
ja ich hatte zwei kinder die es zu
versorgen kalt ich musste um jeden preis
wieder eine arbeit finden fabriken
fabrik ist zugegangen
die beide großen konzerne ansorg und
asias sie hochverschuldet sie schlecht
marketing bezirk franken und richtigkeit
von der patron hat industrie-sparte
gewirtschaftet
in der lackierung von omega sie tue sich
vor mechanischer oder billige schlecht
gemacht
[Musik]
wöllstein im kanton baselland des stura
firma orissa betrieb sieht über 100
jahre gibt
ihre ehemalige chef hat im gegensatz zu
andern aber wenig mit mir über die
zweite wo aus sammelt ethisch saubere
die acht gerade auch die oris müsse die
kritieren 260 angestellte und klar hat
aber firma konnte der oris kurz rolf
portmann kennt aber die hufe patrol wort
krise nie verwunden hey das ist
natürlich als persönliches trauma xia
das ist das ist klar das ist sozialer
für viele sichere soziale bus gesehen
oder das prestige verlust das ist das
ist das ist klar
struck ziehen ist schneckenhaus die
einige andere wo das jetzt da man sich
der vorfall am sportplatz umgestellt und
das verschlafene insofern ist mit worten
vor der eigenen strategie war damals
noch auf die mechanik und oft manufaktur
gesetzt das ist schon mein herz nicht
weil wir nicht gern
das ist das ist klar
auf ansatz gehöre städte nicolas hayek
ruf doch tag vor der gläubigerbank vor
der konzerne aus weg und ssi ausruf tag
über die marode uhrenindustrie zu
analysieren und so ist es ganz laxey der
markt für mechanische uhr war ist
zusammengebrochen
zulieferbetriebe im ganzen russische uhr
bog sie vor gut gestanden
nicolas hayeks ist fazit fusionieren
oder billig markt europa ist jetzt
geschafft ich stecke und chef wurde vom
neuen großkonzern einfach keineswegs das
gegenteil ist der fall
ich habe mich erinnere 3 70 sitzige der
hexen am samstag oder sonntag
warum in die mutter texte ist meine
schwester und ich hatte extra etwas
selber mache er hat immer eine schimmere
taxi von ihrer schule machen wieder tun
abhängigkeit wird bald an der zeit soll
ich jetzt mit investieren soll ich das
übernehmen das ist auch dass damit das
konzept so umsetzt wie nähert strategie
entwickelt hat und mehrheitlich aus als
mache zusammen
petra glaubt hat ihre strategie das
unterste marktsegment wieder zu
beherrschen und sich nun auf der luxus
konzentrieren sondern ohne zu
attackieren
wenn man umfragen machen mit dem nicolas
hayek hätte steg wechselt er schlug sie
fordern und wird gern provoziert das
erste mal adel wird verdammt nochmal
quartier chalet was ich sage also schon
dominante figur zu figur keine
nachvollziehen was er macht und wir sind
stolz gemacht hat aber ich habe immer
sehr kindlich sie sehr emotional und
sehr ich bin bei den grizzly bär wo sie
skandale und so macht man rum wo sich
gegründet wurde grizzlybären erkenne
jazz kabarett minister spürt sind dass
ich möchte darlehen und er erwärmt sie
und er schützt sie
nach der übernahme vom neuen konzern
präsentiert sich der gebürtige libanese
1987 ihre familie ihre show vom
schweizer fernsehen tochter nayla person
nick und der großen markt erwarte der
konzern ist der anfang von martina stöhr
schweiz
wer jetzt aus einer fremden von rohren
industrie überhaupt nicht versteht was
wir jetzt dato bringen wir hätten also
doch kopf geschüttelt also dass honig
oder das hat mir schon was hatte ich
danke taktisch haben wir gar kein bild
machen
aber da war ich kenne ihn nicht aber ich
habe dank dass das fusion der messe
sagen dass die chance besteht schon aber
natürlich größer gremien und ich sage
jetzt heißt also dass ich womöglich der
hayek als insider
da werde ich das in amerika passieren
hatte oder justizgeschichte haben aber
als und und ich das natürlich als eine
geschichte wo ist aber dass er bald wird
man vor ort ist nicht mehr hayek mit dem
mietauto analytische reihe kultur
es ist ich glaube dass man mit der bis
neues machen und das ist nicht mehr
schein als sein was ganz wichtig das
heißt eine industrielle partner network
bis hand welle bewege und industrie
halte und vorwärts kicker
ich trample da das sei die kultur box
ist verheerend die kurzen geld müsse
vertrauen kultur cv wir sind die kings
und die könige dh dass man ja gehört hat
man ist das caricatura dass sie quasi
100 franken hinnehmen und damit ihre
zigarren nahezu endet also das ist genau
das paradebeispiel lud wo meine sie hat
immer ihre produkte ohne innovation türe
von tyros lang dass sie der schweiz
gemacht ich es wunderbar swissmetal gold
melodien und das land damit man immer
mehr gewinn machen
bei uns dir das ist nett dass ein
investor die handwerker selber abgesagt
weil die ganze industrie ist bleibt
offen
und da heißt mit riesiger schlösser mit
besitztümer und gleichzeitig ist das
ganze bachab
[Musik]
barrett aber sache der chefetage gefragt
hat ob die mechanische puppen buchmacher
mit bedürfte teures handwerk lockt die
wz stellt klaus zimmermann findige
mechanische und der firma an neue show
er hat seine kreationen sie im
firmeneigenen museum ausgestellt
daher muss er denke da vinci mit
verschiedenen modelle probook machten
den uhrmachern als hauptschuldigen
armbanduhr ihrer bauern eine zukunft
programmiert inklusive exakte art von
der mondphase da vinci
wir hätten vorher eigentlich die ganze
geschichte vor der iwc darum kämpft zum
die genaueste uhr zu machen wo möglich
sind dass sich nun übergangen gegen
kürzungen
denn wir müssen uns überlegen was hat
mehrere machen dass die uhr
die mechanischen uhren wieder attraktiv
werden und so an ich den einfach einmal
durfte zieht sogar um eine freie tag
wenn es nur darum gegangen ist meinte er
du zwar nur vier tag pro woche
geschaffen
genau an dem tag x roberto von der
taschenuhr werk das kalendarium aufbauen
und es hat denn sogar funktioniert und
sie stehen einfach glücklich und wie es
auf der geschäftsleitung denn so oft
nova
das zeigt ja man sollte eigentlich
probiere man zurück bis zu machen
für gutklassig längst pensioniert aber
wird marketingabteilung von iwc ist er
gut über zwei jahre ist die ganze welt
unterwegs und erzählt von seinem sohn
felix ihr herstellung und auch nie so
platzierte sie
es gibt einen überblick wo wieder gott
als allah als wir im wasser
es ist einfach die faszination drin dir
die hand nicht ausmachen
und es ist zum beispiel jetzt vor wie
bitte
musik wechseln das ereignis hat erwin
jimmy thimm ewiger kalender
doch in der halle wo seine lokalen hände
die silvesternacht ruf gelogen
ich sehe wir langsam die zahl münze
verschwimmt und auf 20 über gott und das
ist einfach dass ich der seherlebnis und
ich höre ich würde mir wünsche
ich würde es nochmal erleben darf man
mal verein ist gott einfach nicht kurz
lang bis sich der vorgang wiederum
abspielt was da vinci führer luxusmarkt
ist swatch für den binnenmarkt schicht
von swatch hat angefangen bevor nicolas
hayek dort nämlich an der herstellung
oder mechanische uhrwerk der damalige
direktor des konkret ruft der junge
ingenieur des schafes das sind die
ersten swatch da ist immer diese
berühmte schale in die alles eingebaut
wurde und die verschiedenen farben die
ganz zu beginn verwendet wurde
wenn ich mich recht erinnere gab es
schon ende 1979 die ersten befehl aus
der direktion eine schweizer uhr zu
entwickeln die nichts kostet und
qualitativ hervorragendes und gefährde
auftrag nur robust und industriell hart
steht für die franken
diese schnapsidee das ist genau die
skizzierte gewacht haben an diesem tag
und zur atom chemisch zusammengestellt
gestochen und geschlagen ich war sein
münchen bonn hat mich gefragt ob ich
wahnsinnig bin ob ich irgendeine idee
von geld habe weshalb ich hier
arbeiteten ich wurde zusammengeschossen
gut das papier hat der tomke behalten
und ich bin zu mir zurückgekommen mit
der meinung dass ich will das ist
schiefgegangen
zwei stunden später kam die general der
der technische direktor mit dem ich noch
nie ein gespräch hatte vorher sie wollen
spielen okay dann sieht man nimmt er
will alle zeichnungen sechs monat haben
sie verlieren alle in nato projekt der
sie haben nur noch eine priorität das zu
realisieren
durisol theo posen und am anfang waren
alle anderen dagegen wir waren wirklich
isoliert
nach jedem arbeitstag mussten wir bilanz
ziehen und ich fragte mich bin ich
normal oder die anderen alle welt war
gegen uns und es war schwierig und
brauchte kraft den eingeschlagenen weg
weiterzugehen
sechs monate später hat man roter typen
gehabt die zeiger sind die umgekehrte
richtung gegangen so schlecht haben wir
das konstruktion gemacht mit müller und
danach wieder nochmals sechs monate
bekommt dann nämlich endlich prototyp
gehabt funktioniert haben und die haben
die fünf stück haben drei tag her sie
überlebt und dann hat der tod gesagt
okay wenn sie drei tage überlebt haben
die wertung zu nieren
swatch ich wäre der billigung des lagers
als modeaccessoire botschaft ist aus
restrukturierungen beschrieb trainer
hätte es besser gewusst rettete nicola
sales marketing und vertrieb zu der
hauptfiliale industriepolitik gemacht so
ist zum schweizer uhren und luftigen
betracht kommt ziele these dass nummer
war massa produziert industrie überhaupt
legal und dass das mit robusten schweiz
möglich ist 1914 inszenierte die 100
millionen stieg
das ist der neue schweizer kultur
2010 nummer paar monate nach dem tod von
nicolas hayek ceo befindet versorgt zu
einer erhöhung der markt und der stadt
hätten drei autos trat vor der branche
eine freude gemacht dass ich schon früh
das macht freude dass man nichts meint
preis sagen wie ihre posten bekommt das
schon besser wenn man noch am leben ist
eine anerkennung für einen erfinder
tausend jahre später
ich musste etwas schmunzelnd ich muss
ihnen gestehen wir gehen wollten sie den
preis ja gar nicht an
nein natürlich schützt man die liste wir
sind alle irgendwo egoisten es hat
geholfen klarheit zu schaffen all diesen
vermeintlichen fehlern des wortes und
hat ein paar dinge richtig gestellt
die swatch group heißt swatch group
wieder zu stellen obwohl mehr
der größte ölkonzern in luxus bereich
sehr gut aussehend zweitstimme die ich
für die größten umsatz machte den
konzern sondern andere marken vor das
wort stand ich trotzdem philosophie von
dem konzern immer noch zurück das heißt
massenproduktion bringt innovation im
wert sie so viel wachstum mega
oderbrücke das ist nicht wichtig für zu
wichtig ist dass sie stets stückzahl
mäßig wachst will das geht die suite und
möglichkeit die industrielle basis
verbreitern
der konzern wird die autopreise gemeint
präsent sie und alle bestandteile für
mechanische und elektronische oder
selber herstellen als gutes beispiel für
das ist firma nova rocks konnten im
neuenburger jura
hier zeigt sich dass wir dominant
swatch-gruppe hüttig christian völker
und orangerie viele video das
hightech-unternehmen wo rund 30
angestellte schaffen
moderne die maschine produziert die
künste und exklusiv delhi für
mechanische bruder
bestandteile für tour war sicher blätter
oder super musikstücke und so mehr gut
das exklusivste stück vom namen ich habe
die sogenannte spiralen spirale trip zur
kürzung hartz iv mechanische uhr
wann die bg die spirale der oft wird
programm iranische uru frau verzichten
und das großes wasser braucht für
darstellung kassel entscheidet zwei
gruppen
[Musik]
das richtig anfühlt platzt fast vor
stolz wurden mit rohmaterial zeigt für
die bundes spirale
das ist unser tresor da sehen sie den
draht aus dem die spirale hergestellt
wird diesen draht zu bändigen es die
wichtigste aufgabe bei uns zehntausend
franken
und da es diesen rat kann man jetzt die
spirale fertigen genau aber es braucht
noch einige arbeitsgänge bis zur spirale
das ist das grundmaterial der berühmte
trat aus dem das herz der low gemacht
wird das ist ein großes werk sie von uns
sein jan hajek der an uns geglaubt hat
die sogenannte reglose der spirale die
plattform ihr vater zu mir überraschung
des freiheitsplatzes sie wettet die
modernste maschinen anlagen insbesondere
brücke die meisten diese spiralen
braucht mittlere maschinell borgne
spirale wird pro tag vier sekunden ab
mit der vorhand gerichtete ist es nur
die spirale muss von hand bearbeitet
werden wegen der präzision
man muss sie eine form geben sie bieten
und das ist sie individuell jede
reagiert gleich
aber je nachdem wo man sie berührt
reagiert sie anders die reckless
unterschiedlich korrigieren könnte sagen
die spirale ist lebendig sie biegt hängt
alles vom typ mit dem man sie bereit
je nachdem reagiert sein besonderes
geschenk um eine spirale von hand zu
geben das geld nicht sofort
im schnitt braucht es ein bis eineinhalb
stunden
das ist die schwierigkeit die baselworld
2011 der größten der welt ist sind
raster schweizer jura gros der
uhrenindustrie geht's wieder bestens
sie beschäftigt über 15 siegen die beste
marke gehört zu den drei großen
konzernumbau
die große alte traditionsmarke rolex sie
unabhängig bleiben
unübersehbar ist dominanz von der swatch
gruppe ihre leckeren zur marke becker
dominanz hat man ja nur sondern ich
stehe dominanz im interesse von
gesamtgebilde hat sich die gesamte
uhrenindustrie entwickelt die das ist
doch immer sagen die hat sich
fantastisch entwickelt
mehr sorge dafür dass der gesamtkirche
größer wird also es geht um verträge
wettkampf innere industrie sondern auf
der welt kämpfe mehr gemeinsam über die
schweizer uhrenindustrie ag die
japanische ohren in die strikte indische
und chinesische tv produkt auf den markt
kommen sie wollen die macht anteil könne
und so ist mir etwas mehr alle gemeinsam
hat damals gleich an in trance dass man
vorwärts geld und wenn sie nur geld die
industrie wie viel der markt gewachsen
ist hat viel mehr platz für viele
unternehmen jetzt viel mehr platz auch
für die große und jeder macht wachstum
[Musik]
zum schluss war es letztmals war der jet
war es anfang der uhrmacher luigi
bersani werkstatt die klappe maschine
faktoren einen ort der hätte mechanische
war und jetzt aber lang gesammelt hat
strom für diese tour satzteile hat für
machine click und riesige heimelige
werkstatt ist mein paradies
das heißt dass es mir hier gut geht hier
vergesse ich den stress den ich tagsüber
bin ich zu nichts verpflichtet wenn ich
nichts machen will dann mache ich nichts
machen ja manchmal schaue ich nur ein
bisschen rum oder suche etwas in einer
schublade tue so als ob ich arbeiten
würde
für alois stettner nach der passionierte
schnittstelle ziemlich passion weiter
pflegen und anträge und ganz für sich
allein
[Musik]